[Music]
hey what's up this is bill burr and
today I'm at the all things comedy
studio we're gonna be playing poker with
John Reed put him in a body bag Johnny
Burke the machine crusher who the [ __ ]
else is here [ __ ] deal Vaughn play
that monkey boy and Steve Rannazzisi
let's see the wackiness ensue so all
right we're gonna play we're gonna get
your this is your bias this is this is
this is high stakes poker $60 the
American dollars these are dollars the
white ones are dollars these are $10 the
green ones these are twenty five the red
ones and these are hundred the black one
and a progressive move the white chip is
worth the least by the way does everyone
know how to play Texas Holdem yes Texas
Hold'em is super simple so you take a
deck of cards you get some fellows
together not saying you can't have women
everyone gets two cards dealt down is
around abetting the first three cards
called the flop is like a Royal Flush
then it's the river then it's the I
never play poker there's straight is a
straight flush I don't watch poker is
royal straight flush
I don't care about poker I mean you know
what the deal is if you have people on
your cards that's a good thing my thing
is just take the money and get out of
here I never played before except the
other time we did an episode of this I
think we played orgasm she looks like
Elvis lip goes up to the side Bing I
want to hear a Bobby Lee steve-o so we
do [ __ ] looked at my cards
oh god we lied about it all right John
one down three up one down three up this
is gonna become to help you alright
thank you
one down oh that's one a of a good
secret we did the secret time on stage
somebody's Stanhope and Doug Benson Oh
Spence it says I can guess anyone
age and Stanhope goes I can guess
anyone's weight and I go I'll guess
their secret he goes I'm 22 I weigh 170
pounds I go what's your secret and he
goes I lost my virginity to my sixth
grade teacher I just killed this whole
story and he lost his virginity to a
sixth grade teacher and so I go this not
me to the sixth grade I just want to get
to the part where we [ __ ] their 6th
grade teacher yeah yeah the beginning
was mediocre the guy ended up sixth
grade when he had six graders and by the
way I found this woman on Facebook 200
more stars the teacher I [ __ ]
friended her what subjects did you teach
doesn't seem like a math teacher
oh wow it was math teacher wise you
think they do the numbers
join that [ __ ] heads to [ __ ]
experts right one down one up and I want
to get in real now get the shades of
that just like checker at night
all right is these a 20 so what soy goes
out or is that game yeah all raise 125
I'm gonna commit anymore all right one
down one up it's just me and bill what's
an 8 you're up bill can I just say let's
[ __ ] do it yeah two queens do I have
the three I didn't have the three hey
you gotta get you off at a nascent of
four ah
when bluffing comes back to bite you in
the ass we'll be back after these
messages
or play great okay I played aggressive
yet tight I bluffed by just [ __ ]
throwing chips in like I think I have
something
there was no tell because everyone was
too busy telling stories my betting
strategy is Bluff blah blah blah always
bluffing court Bluff on Maury Povich
Bluff whenever smart is that strategy I
think I employed Steve like knows the
game he's just got that villain in him
he definitely has some lives in his past
I'm not supposed to bring it up I mean
that was one of the greatest Bluffs of
all time my poker face I can hold this
for hours every hand I'm not the father
I don't have anything nothing nothing
like get that money get them hoes get
that house get that pool Ari and I try
to cheat a commerce one time we went
down in commerce that's [ __ ] holy and
what playing poker we're playing like
two five blinds and they have these
chips with the silver in the middle what
do you guys have against getting the
cards to them so we ever said you know
if you ever get kings or higher like
right away put the silver chip down on
and the other guy will start to raise
the pot up and try to get more money
into the pot assume you were gonna win
so Ari didn't have a chip he got Kings
or whatever he didn't have the chip and
he just puts a chip down and I'm like
two seats away and he's trying to like
kick me under the table and finally he
turns me he goes whoa guys like we all
just heard you trying to whisper he goes
do you have a good hand and I'm just
gonna fold right yeah hey we took my kid
to go see Santa Claus
first time in the mall and it was a
great Santa had a real beard I remember
look there's a lot of kids I get mad
when they find out there's no Santa
Claus
I felt cool like oh I know I know some
adult [ __ ] I just told my daughter's
really yeah how old are they well
they're not watching it 11 and 13 13 get
that far guy you know what 13 I [ __ ]
it up because like one two years ago
they put up a GoPro
so I helped him put it off I go we'll
see if we can catch Santa I walk in I'm
a mitten on bells and a flashlight and I
get underneath the GoPro and I jump down
and I flash the light around you're
gonna hear the bells jingling and then I
take the glove I gab the GoPro flip it
around I then go put it in final cut and
slice out me walking in and it's
seamless and I leave it at the very end
of the tape so my daughter's see that
and this this is where I [ __ ] up
Georgia sees it and goes this is real
and I was like yeah my dad was like Oh
buddy I think you might have just [ __ ]
your kid up oh yeah and so she had like
vivid proof of there being a Santa Claus
and then we have a scene taraj later on
she'll go dad love me and that's why he
went to this effort
already with the ring calm I put the Elf
on the Shelf yeah outside on the street
dude and I hang it out there and
everything's it like oh the elf rang the
doorbell like you'll never take it to
the level I took it to you ready for
this [ __ ] elf on a string we all got
that one
I got Santa Claus in my [ __ ] phone
who dials every Christmas at midnight he
calls
it's my [ __ ] Uncle Pete
really is the best
oh you're the best all right you're
being recorded by the way I'll I'll give
you a call later can I have that number
you guys are [ __ ] idiots you going
too far with it oh you feel you've built
the whole [ __ ] world if you just say
it if you just [ __ ] say it and then
you don't add all this [ __ ] Apple
Steve Jobs [ __ ] to it the kid eventually
is gonna be like yeah that's [ __ ] up
how can somebody fly around in a sleigh
with deers and come down to think you
guys start doing video and share how
much ya much you want to bet in four
years I got a call from Bill Bert and
etomidate Anna yeah you gotta do you
know
let's do it I'll just say there was and
then and then hahaha just saying it
after you're crazy do we've had Jewish
kids at our house at New Year's Eve
crying going loves everybody who's like
Santa says you want an iPad when you see
your kids believe like you're drunk your
children let's just keep playing all
right feel you're up by the way if you
want to hit on the Queen you hit on that
Queen player all right I'll go 50 more
bucks better get in there yeah I'm gonna
ride this one out guys oh I like all of
you and I'm gonna tell you right now you
should stand down on this pot okay cuz
I'm thinkin this one all right I'll take
Ward up John I think I might as well no
wait I should have folded family I had
an older brother that was in he told me
he was dead you but he told me he goes
it's no Santa Claus
oh man I thought was cool how old were
you when he told you it's like first
grade oh my ruined right
that explains a lot my second year he
[ __ ] up the third grade and my dad had
a one for all all for one policy oh god
it was like he stand back everybody
thought that adults that the boys
matured later so he said let's keep them
all back so we all had to go down to the
bus stop like three of us we all failed
we all stayed back one of the first bits
I did in my cup comm stand up it's
hilarious I remember he learnt you learn
how to read in first grade which I did
and just the first three months his
people who's trying to sound off the
words go like Boop you're plowing
through it
jokes I ever did was the kid's gonna
look - dude - dude I was like duck first
a second year a first grade they all ran
together I learned that there was no
Santa Claus
that was awesome yeah because I don't
think I got into the whole yeah you
never even got in to get it right oh
good I found out in like seventh eighth
grade seventh or eighth let's play that
monkey boy I don't know what that means
both do your southern twang that sounded
cool
see ya monkey time you don't have to bet
you can just check I'll check yeah yeah
well you've already bluffed this far I'm
not bluffing this time I'm telling you
guys straight up your kings I'm gonna
[ __ ] tell you right I'm just letting
you know that you know I'm trying to do
your favor here at 25 30 35 40 45 50 yet
oh well that was Wow
Island you could have told me we're
gonna do that before gonna call 50 more
to call yeah this would be a big one oh
no I got 10 I don't have it I can't
afford it three tons - Queen - ten go
[ __ ] yourself what do you guys check and
I got the ACE Oh [ __ ] straight well
to say that I like the gamble part I
like to Bluff I like to feel the
butterflies in their stomach so I got it
so close I'll ever get to a first kiss
since I've been married for 14 years
Paul Kirk is like golf where it's like
exciting in the beginning then after a
while is I just want it to be over I
don't I don't like to go too crazy
unless I'm confident but that's what
everyone does when they played poker
it's like I give a [ __ ] what I play golf
for about two holes then it's just like
[ __ ] man it's hot out here I don't do
well in the Sun if I'm drinking I'll be
pretty slow if I'm sober all bets are
off let's just get to the clubhouse and
start drinking and like I feel like
pokers the same way I'm trying to win
and then after a while there's a big
part of me that just wants to lose fight
your great-great-grandfather fighting
the Civil War his dad might have fought
in the grid like 81 in 1910 I hate to do
this but Theo's got a really good story
I'll just tell it and he's better when
you tell someone else's story because
you're not attached to the truth yeah
one time he was 15 he stole his dad's
car he's gonna go to a party so we
pulled up put on his driving dog he
pours himself a vodka and Mountain Dew
and he starts driving to this party in
from his town Lewisburg to Evansville
and on the way there he is lost by the
party in the process of cop pulls him
over and says son where you going - he
says Evansville where you coming from he
goes Evansville
like if you owned up to it actually yeah
drive your mouse on amigo you let you go
that's a good times dude I like the
doubt of the Mountain Dew and vodka yeah
what were you drinking Mountain Dew and
vodka popular sipper but isn't it Dale
Earnhardt's drink
yeah new the dude I gotta [ __ ] go
hard lunch on one hand I think at this
point you don't I think you just slowly
back out of the game the way you have
since we sat down Hey tune into all
things comedy we're Bert Kreischer plays
in the safe slowly backs out I'm gonna
get a cholesterol test up next all right
what are we doing here all right you
ready yeah I don't think I put my name I
was just red on red violence again I'm
out
well you don't have to be out well then
I'll stay in okay $25 guess what what
this is this is the law we need 25 to
call you can raise if you want to
yeah I'm just calling all right all
right let's have fun let's see it Oh
didn't see that one coming did you I'm
gonna go 50 bucks to you John you can
bet or raise you got all that money over
there if you're so back you [ __ ] [ __ ]
here hundred okay I let you go I don't
know why you would listen to me but
right back at you Wow
two sevens oh you [ __ ]
he held on whew I thought I had two tens
I don't I never play poker ever
John Reid very subtly cerebral player
thickish kind of little fella might be
Irish might just be chromosomally kind
of not fully advanced vo I did look like
he knew what he was doing I feel super
conservative definitely excited that
Trump is in office just rocking that
Joey Lawrence haircut
I'm so [ __ ] jealous bill burr he has
that tall aggressive premature baby look
right here god damn it he's got great
hair you son of a [ __ ] I think me and
run is easier the only to be able to
know to play poker Bert Kreischer who is
busy telling stories the entire time
kind of paying attention but kind of not
Bert Kreischer is an emotional mess I
think that is gonna play into my
disadvantage he just turns into a
giggling schoolgirl you didn't play
great I don't think Steve Rannazzisi
everybody thought he died at 9/11 but he
didn't is he good at cards who knows is
he a ghost who knows who wants to switch
cards with me right I'll switch cards
are you here here we go well what a new
thing yeah I've not even looked at him
having looked at him I'll stay with
these guys the Hulbert [ __ ] with me
bird [ __ ] with me Bert oh not one
good course okay Bert you want to smile
drunk bird I'll switch back no I'm not
[ __ ] the top of the [ __ ] no I'm not
everything these are really good but the
only you look at bars anyone wanna bet
right now exactly they have the best
cards right now John hasn't I'll bet you
any amount of money you know the best
cards Wow do it that's pretty confident
yep
oh wow doubled up with that straight I
stare 2,000 yards - it oh yeah
a hundred bucks says he's full of
[ __ ] should I go [ __ ] I believe him
but I'm gonna go against him anyway okay
that's crazy
yeah and then he's gettin off him okay
when I went Wow are you [ __ ] kidding
me
you're gonna lose buddy you guys won't
see two more races right now oh no way
do you have aces to Tim's rotten if you
wanna run oh I don't want to catch a ten
you can win the pie okay oh you want to
run him out keep playing no wait that
was all about this [ __ ] right all right
we'll take will you get this yeah that
money's done why is that supposed to me
yeah cuz I feel bad that I lost agree
with him dude you've got to get a road
manager you're just like yeah yeah yeah
you good we took some random side mats
just to make things interesting and what
I didn't understand was something that
Steve and Bert just randomly switched
hands you know we got dealt the two
cards down and then he just decided to
switch cars I mean which was a
tremendous mistake it's not hard to
screw over your friends in poker
especially when no one at the table do
you really consider a close friend
here's the problem I was getting such
[ __ ] cards at one point I wait you know
what let's make it interesting and this
is really fun to do let's switch cards
there's just something about Bert he
just seems to be enjoying himself to a
level that was not allowed when I was
growing up I had six eight the entire
time I got six eight six five five six
five eight seven eight five six I got
that was what I got every single hand
and then two aces show up give him to
read Susie that piece of [ __ ] I'll take
his pocket aces any day in a week but I
already had one like a lot of money
[Laughter]
nobody's looking nobody's looking nobody
while I stood 25 25 best hand nobody
looking he's coming to let's see the
flop and let's bet on the flop
okay I said interesting this is a blind
hand we're not looking at our cards
alright so let me just explain this from
what I'm seeing
okay two hearts King high I see the same
thing no one it's weird
I see it this way to just I see exactly
I see a green felt too are you seeing
that see that's the green felt all right
how would you bet on that on that flop
let's go all in blind what we're doing
no no no
[Applause]
we were told everybody owes baddest sex
now yeah but there's enough women out
there what would you rather have an ugly
chick who is amazing at sex or a hot
chick that was horrible at sex me too
we're talking like just rough to look at
like rough when you have sex with the
hot chick when she has sex you I
couldn't handle the weirdness of that
dr. nose guy there's two kind of guys
guys that like to get naked in public
and guys that didn't like it everybody
would get naked all the time drop of a
hat at a party I said [ __ ] guy is
either funny yeah scary yeah that's it
streaks across like you're watching a
football game a guy runs across the
field [ __ ] hilarious walking home by
yourself and a guy I got a three got a
Paris I want a election for [ __ ] on
a pizza box and for 180 people I was
definitely the naked guy you did that in
front of people underwear you have a
girlfriend at the time yeah she stayed
with you she wasn't there shouldn't see
it did you have to [ __ ] or recycle
I had to show dye done that I'd given a
speech to you before told you [ __ ] on
command yeah good yeah now but I
definitely then and I was like oh my
buddy's like gonna give a speech taken I
was like no I got a [ __ ] they're like oh
that would be hilarious I was like okay
so they got up put out a pizza box I
just came out naked and I was like
turned round and [ __ ] on top of the
pizza on top of the pizza box hit it
perfectly Wow place goes [ __ ] nuts
people are jumping out of windows and
then we go and then they bring everyone
back in they do the tally the votes
and I won by a [ __ ] land the guy went
that you lost he was like women the guys
just got the guy that I lost feathers
Josh young and he said this is [ __ ]
and some guy in the back goes no it's
bird [ __ ] oh yeah this made me want
pizza all of a sudden there's something
about betting your your money where it
makes you vulnerable just sitting there
playing poker you're surrounded by dudes
cards food it's very comfortable
poker makes the people tell stories and
guys just feel free to talk about
whatever so I think you can't tell
what's real and what's not but then
that's what's great about comedy anyway
and once you get into that spot then you
start dumping out stuff I mean some guys
almost too free I learned some things
today I didn't want to know and I hope
they cut it out let's go blind yeah
[ __ ] idiot that's okay it doesn't
wait so let's look at it I know what
mine are I'm looking at I'm playing so
this is just for the pop let's put it
all no let's put a rolling oh all of it
go for the pot god damn it go for the
pot all my work is pointless
alright damn this does kind of here
alright fine
for the record I had lined it up like
there's like no there's like no [ __ ]
alright pull them back back flop it out
and then we'll play it right yeah yeah
there we go we'll play for pinks very
antique laughing gear flop it out oh
this guy's the coldest [ __ ] oh great
this guy there is a definite straight
ace high nine Jack
nine Jack will be a good one all right
we throw it out yeah go I got the 900
and eight to eight the nine wins so far
hold on guys what do you have you ready
I got parent nothing [ __ ] Jackie
oh ho ho a couple tens
this is network there we go right there
Oh mine there we go where's the camera
right there you see that this is what
the [ __ ] I do did bill win yes he won he
won all the money yeah of course he won
gee I wonder why
could we be at the all things comedy
studio and it's his Network shooting me
all things comedy poker network dude
good job you know not really the
building to beat him in but I'd like to
see him out in these streets hey listen
there's a reason we're here bill we got
it you know what I'm saying
like set tall premature baby out in
these streets I'm happy for you
maybe you'll get a TV show one day I
won't with like a pair of tens of some
[ __ ] was pathetic but it made me feel
good about myself
you know I'm gonna call my wife and let
her know that I wanted then a winners
coming home winners coming home honey
have dinner ready all right thank you
wait again
hey guys thanks for watching this is our
thing it's all things comedy so do us a
favor
like subscribe share tell your friends
at the coffee school so we've been
drinking a little bit have a great day